you are looking at the top of New
England's highest peak Mount Washington
in New Hampshire and guess what it's a
mild day at the home of what's been
called the world's worst weather in
February it recorded what may be the
lowest wind chill in U.S history
109 degrees below zero is that Nancy I
hope that's not Nancy for our series
pushing the limits we met the
researchers who collect weather and
climate data in extreme conditions their
data helps shape work around the world
including on Mount Everest our Nancy
Chen traveled up the 6200 foot Mount
Washington to learn more work together
and you all bump Mount Washington not a
place you want to be and the air
temperatures could smash records our
journey to some of the most extreme
weather on earth started at Mount
Washington's base in New Hampshire this
is what we're taking all the way to the
top as we jumped aboard a snow cap
climb more than 60 200 feet up New
England's tallest peak
seven eight miles an hour
oh that's not bad we're traveling with a
team of researchers as they change
shifts Cruz rotates spending the week at
the summit's observatory there
definitely are other places on the
planet that experience weather like this
but no one's there Jay broccolo is the
director of weather operations for the
observatory a non-profit dedicated to
understanding weather and climate so you
feel like you're experiencing weather
history oh absolutely
and being a part of History happens
often
in February the wind chill here plunge
to a record
109 degrees below zero
something to look forward to as we
finally reach the summit two and a half
bumpy hours later all right
made it to the top now the adventure
really begins
Matt Washington's latitude height and
atmosphere make it uniquely prone to
extreme weather
which is why observers collect
measurements day and night
[Music]
365 days a year you have our Max weather
Observer Hayden Pearson showed us how so
when we go outside for the observations
we take what's called a sling
psychometer which we keep in this heated
little box right here and it has two
thermometers on it despite advances in
technology it's the same instrument
they've been using for 90 years to
ensure consistent and accurate record
keeping researchers head out every hour
on the hour to track temperature and
humidity on this day the wind chill was
22 below zero
uh I don't think there is a too cold so
no limit you are out here doing this
every day every hour
observers also record wind speed on
instruments that feed to the National
Weather Service so when you're up here
you can see five states two countries
and one ocean
you're bad for an office view so very
large area low pressure developing from
the highest point at the peak we could
also see tomorrow's weather that's the
actual storm front that's working its
way in from the southeast so that's the
storm right there that is the storm yes
just 12 hours later a different scene
this is what it looks like after a
snowstorm came in overnight visibility
right now is zero because we are in the
cloud dropping snow on the land below
so you're in what's producing the
weather as well which is pretty neat
it's kind of like storm chasing but
instead of chasing it we wait for it to
come to us
shape forecast Nationwide increasing to
35. building on the work of generations
that came before The Observatory
maintains what is now one of North
America's longest continuous climate
records there are stations that collect
information like you do but they're
without humans without people doing
something with it it's not the same kind
of research yeah there's not people
there so a lot of times they'll take
that data and just assume it's right
because the instrumentation said that's
what it is so there's nothing quite like
the human touch yeah exactly that
accurate research matters and
understanding climate change climate is
made up of daily weather patterns and
those daily weather patterns slowly
slowly change over time and that's what
makes up our climate and here we get to
see it we get to live in it and we get
to see what happens after the fact are
you able to see climate change here yeah
we can we've noted uh you know a slight
increase in temperature up on the summit
we've seen shorter snow Seasons the
melting out of snow is a occurring a
little bit earlier how we grow Food for
People how we Supply water how we clean
water sure it all matters it all ends up
you know back to weather patterns 12 to
18 inches of snow which is why
researchers and volunteers continue to
staff the observatory so you guys work
together and you all bunk together too
yeah I mean we spread out when we can
they sleep cook and eat together before
unwinding at the end of the day there's
another Toadette in this race ultimately
up in the clouds Brockwell says the
observatory is a family everyone's here
to do the same purpose they want to be a
part of the history there's so many
hearty Souls that have spent time of
their life on the summit and being part
of that is really meaningful and
fulfilling you do feel very proud of
what we do and that goes a long way
on top of all that it is worth noting
the fastest wind speed ever directly
observed by humans was also on Mount
Washington that was back in 1934 at
231 miles per hour not that cold when we
were there but still pretty cold yeah I
like the phrase spread out when we can
they go from the top bunk to the bottom
bunk
and Nancy what was that like for you I'm
thinking was Shauna Thomas the big
cheese mad at you
it's it's terrifying to me to be that
cold it is it's pretty cold I I would
say you bundle up a lot there's that
saying there's not bad weather just bad
clothing and so you wear several several
layers I will say uh my nostrils hurt
for a good two or three days after I
couldn't even tell it was you in a lot
of those shots yeah the Hat I think
stays indoors Nancy thank you very much